now you've heard stories of bravery and
survival just like that from what during
the pearl harbor attack one story though
hasn't always been accurate that's right
local filmmakers born in a net hole they
began their documentary telling the
story of the naval school of music but
after interviewing historians and
survivors of the uss arizona they wanted
to set the record straight about the
ship's 20-piece band young talented and
brave men on board and playing the
morning colors
it's the story of 21 men
21 young men musicians aboard the uss
arizona they stare right back at you
and when you see that picture they come
a lot the only band in history formed
and trained together
and fought and died together the myth is
that
on when the bombs hit on december 7th
that the band was in their hammocks that
they were asleep they were asleep not
true says lou contour one of only two
living survivors from the ship they laid
down their instruments and ran to the
general quarter station we
were alive for about 12 minutes on the
ship blew up it's their story and
sacrifice that inspired las vegas
filmmakers annette and warren hull they
mattered these 21 sailors immortalized
in the documentary a band to honor a
labor of love for the holes my dad was a
world war ii veteran
and
you know we're losing all of them
more than 2400 americans were killed in
the attack on pearl harbor a date which
will live in infamy
1177 of those lives were lost on board
the uss arizona she was the greatest
loss of life of any ship in american
naval history every one of those men
who died that day had a story
it was a short story for a lot of them
you know some of them were only 16 17
years old it's a very emotional journey
we take people on a piece of history
comes to life a 20-piece band forever
enshrined
the original score of a band to honor
produced by a green valley high school
graduate holly amber church who now has
a very successful career in hollywood
you could stream this documentary on
voodoo and you can also find it on
blu-ray at the big box retailers quite a
store that's remarkable it really does
take your breath away and it's nice to
be able to have those stories of those
who didn't make it absolutely